We're kicking it off with a mac and cheese make-over
in today's 'Food News'.
Okay. I don't know if anyone here knows
how I feel about mac and cheese.
Yeah we do.
Well, I'm obviously very excited
cause I've been chomping at the mac and cheese bit
for this Pop Sugar reports that
Kraft has turned their classic noodles pink
for Valentine's and they say it's the same classic Kraft
with a taste of just a hint of candy flavor.
Shall we?
Yeah. Aha. I just want to say out loud
it doesn't look super appetizing, right?
Like it's like against nature.
Let's try it.
Oh okay.
Yeah.
Well.
I'm in.
You're in.
Yeah. It's.
They actually I have to say quite have mastered the ratio.
Cause when I heard the mac and cheese was going sweet,
I'm not going to lie I was like ew,
Well check this out.
You get your mac and cheese and then you get this packet.
And so it makes the color and the flavor
just slightly altered.
I'm in.
Really?
Yeah.
Well then you can have mine.
(laughing)
All right well,
and if you're headed into the weekend
feeling just a little broken-hearted this Valentine's season
ready to move on from an ex boyfriend or an ex girlfriend,
well there's news for you.
Delish reports that Hooters wants to help.
Yeah Hooters.
So here's the plan.
If you can shred a photo of your ex
they'll high-five you with some free wings.
You can go to their website,
upload a photo of your ex
and then you can choose
how you want to destroy that picture.
You can shred it and burn it, bury it.
You could throw darts at it, whatever.
And after sweet, sweet catharsis
you get a coupon for 10 wings
which you can cash in at a Hooter's this Valentine's day.
Now, have you ever been to a Hooters?
Huh?
Yeah.
Well I actually have, and we,
Adam Sandler and I did this movie called 'Blended'
and the first scene of the movie takes place at a Hooters
and it turns out his like wife worked there
it is the most meaningful sweet storyline.
And they gave me a gift card for a year's free food
and it was laminated with my pictures on it
and the Hooters logo
and man, I put that in my wallet
and carried it around for a year.
Really. Did you ever go in and use it?
You know, I didn't,
but it's like a trophy to me.
Like my picture next to the Hooters emblem.
I just, I love it.
I love Hooters.
And you know, it's not just Hooters
who wants to help you out
when you go through a breakup or a divorce,
your friends really wanna be there for you
and support you
and sometimes they don't know exactly how.
Word, yeah.
It's like it's sensitive.
So a writer a InStyle just came up with this genius idea
of how to do this.
She was recently divorced.
So she went on Zola, which is a wedding registry site
and she opened up a registry for one.
And there were so many simple things
that she lost in that divorce,
whether it be pots, pans, towels.
And let me tell you,
when you get a divorce
you do have to build your life back up
and as cute and quippy as this story might seem,
this one really caught my attention.
I think this is awesome.
And you don't even have to be married to go through this,
you could have just lived with someone
and I think this is revolutionary,
and it's a great way to make a very difficult situation
celebratory as well as help solve the problem.
Well, I thought about this, you know,
when I thought she was doing it
and I don't judge her or anybody that would do that.
But when I thought would you do it Ross?
There's no way I would do it
because I feel like by saying, I need help
I would feel weak.
And then I thought,
why would you be judging yourself
if you wouldn't judge anybody else for doing it?
And I think there's something so strong in saying
hey friends, family, people I know
I'm struggling, I need help,
I just went through something really hard.
I think that vulnerability is very strong.
And a great way for those
who are tentative on the sidelines,
dying to dive in and be proactive with you,
which is what friends do.
Yes people wanna help right.
I just want to say to this writer
I will be offlining and sidelining with you
because I have an idea inspired by you.
Really?
Yeah, yeah.
Will you fill us in later?
Absolutely.
Stay tuned.
All right before we go,
we got one thing that helps
in every breakup Valentine's day celebration,
you name it it's ice cream.
Oh my God.
What are you doing to me?
And we are loving this Nick's Swedish ice cream brand.
I have eaten so much of it.
There's no sugar in here.
For reals?
Yes, Ross it's all plant-based sweeteners.
So it's like a salad?
With ranch dressing.
Okay.
Even though they actually have vegan options too
and VFS, we love you so much
and we want to get you in on this too.
So you're getting $150 gift card.
For this low-calorie,
sweeter style ice cream brand, Nick's.
And you better use it.
What is going on?
This is-
That is so good.
It is so incredible.
Nick's Whoa,
you are dope and delicious.
(upbeat music)